[Applaudissements]
vous savez qu'on ne sait pas vraiment
comment fonctionne le cerveau
alors on a essayé de répondre à beaucoup
de questions on a des réponses on en a
pas mais ce qu'on sait c'est que nos
cerveaux ils sont très forts pour être
nos servants et ils sont terribles pour
être nos chefs d'orchestre
par exemple pour faire nos impôts pour
souvenir de nos recettes de cuisine
préférée ou encore pour construire une
machine alors là ils sont incroyables
ils font des miracles
par contre quand il s'agit de leur
demander comment faire pour être heureux
et ce que je dois quitter mon conjoint
ou encore des questions philosophiques
plus larges alors là ils sont hyper nuls
ils savent pas quoi faire
mais nos cerveaux ils sont très malins
parce qu'ils nous font croire qu'ils
savent et nous on les croit tellement en
permanence qui finissent par croire qui
savent mieux que nous
et ça c'est pas son danger parce que nos
cerveaux ils finissent par penser agir
et prendre des décisions à notre place
alors on va faire un saut dans le saut
dans l'histoire de 100 ans plus tôt au
début de l'histoire de l'informatique
alors on est en 1829 et cette jeune
femme Ada Lovelace donc c'est une riche
comtesse anglaise qui est passionnée de
mathématiques et son rêve à elle cette
construire une machine qui calcule vite
alors elle dit votre débout toute sa vie
tout son argent mais faute de fond elle
va pas au bout du projet par contre elle
publie son travail
le premier programme informatique
et ça fait d'elle la première cause de
l'histoire
alors Adam on va l'oublier une centaine
d'années à peu près
et son travail va se retrouver dans les
mains d'Alan Turing qui sont inspirent
pour inventer le premier ordinateur la
machine de Turing
et Alan il est bien entouré dans son
équipe il a plein de femmes dont une
Johan Clark qui est une cryptologue de
génie d'ailleurs qui a participé à
décoder Enigma
vous savez Enigma c'est cette machine
qui était utilisée par l'Allemagne Nazi
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale pour
quitter les messages
et on estime qu'avec cette manœuvre on a
écourté la garde de deux ans
ensuite en 1959 dans un milieu pas
vraiment connu pour être féminin qui est
la marine américaine on retrouve une
autre femme
donc Grace Hopper qu'une femme de
caractère sa doctrine c'est il vaut
mieux demander la permission pendant il
vaut mieux demander pardon que demander
la permission et alors la permission de
l'a pas demandé et elle a créé le
premier compilateur vous savez c'est ce
programme que vous avez sur vos
téléphones et vos ordinateurs qui
traduit des instructions en code
exécutables pour l'ordinateur
mais en fait les femmes il y en avait
plein
même à la NASA dans les années 60 et
grâce à elle
margar est Hamilton les américains ils
ont pu mettre le pied sur la Lune lors
de la mission Apollo 11
en fait Margaret elle dirigée toute
l'équipe informatique qu'à godet de
logiciel de la fusée
et heureusement qu'elle était là parce
que c'est logiciel car pris la main à
deux minutes de la lumière
c'est d'ailleurs à elle qu'on doit le
terme de software ingénieur qu'on
utilise encore beaucoup aujourd'hui
mais alors toutes ces femmes
elles ont marqué l'histoire elles vont
révolutionner l'informatique
les connaissez-vous
on avait vous déjà entendu parler
on a qui disent oui je sais que c'est
pas bon
alors moi je suis ingénieur en
informatique de formation je travaille
dans la date un millier en plein essor
avec la datation l'intelligence
artificielle ou le champ des possibles
et infini
j'ai accompagné j'accompagne les
entreprises dans leur transformation
profonde pour remettre la data au cœur
de leur business
avec la data on analyse on optimise et
on améliore les performances des
entreprises mais pas que les
performances par exemple en optimisant
toute la chaîne logistique on est
capable de diminuer nos émissions
carbone
la data en fait en 2022 c'est le sujet
d'innovation on construit le manque de
demain
j'ai commencé ma carrière en 2014
dans une équipe où il y avait moins de
10% de filles j'étais d'ailleurs la
seule de l'open space
et à cette époque j'ai senti et vécu la
minorité
quand il y avait des visiteurs à mon
étage il passait me regardait il
s'arrêtait et puis s'en allait un peu
comme dans un zoo en fait je me sentais
différente extraterrestre et j'avais
souvent le besoin de me mettre de côté
pour être tranquille et être sûr qu'on
me regarde pas
mais en fait à l'époque de Margaret à la
NASA dans les années 60
créent le software c'est le rôle des
femmes
les hommes eux ils construisent créent
le hardware
et la mécanique la construction le
hardware ça c'était des secteurs
d'hommes les femmes elles étaient
assistantes secrétaire et développeuse
et si on compare avec nos smartphones
aujourd'hui
imaginez que tout le monde voulait créer
une téléphone et que personne voulait
créer les logiciels les applications et
l'interface utilisateur
c'est assez d'être délirant non
mais en fait à l'époque c'est assez
normal de penser que le software
l'intelligence de l'ordinateur doit être
lié au rang des tâches administratives
en une phrase les hommes sont les
constructeurs et les femmes les secrets
mais tout ça ce sont les conséquences
des métiers stéréotypés de l'époque
et dans les années 60 on retrouve la
moitié des employés du milieu
informatique qui sont des femmes
ensuite émerge la globalisation les
métiers comme la mécanique la
construction le hardware qui sont
délocalisés à l'étranger à bas coût et
ils perdent peu à peu leur attrait et
leur prestige
en revanche la filière informatique à
côté est devenue secteur d'innovation et
devient de plus en plus intéressantes
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est que tout le
monde veut faire du software les
universités vont leur première formation
et si on regarde les chiffres ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans les secteurs
dans le secteur de la science
les femmes sont en constante
augmentation depuis les années 70
sauf en informatique
les chiffres dégringolent à partir des
années 80
comment on passe de 50 % à moins de 20%
aujourd'hui
alors la théorie les ordinateurs
personnels arrivent sur le marché
dans les années 80 à peu près avec un
marketing très visé des publics des
publicités avec des hommes pour les
hommes et leur fils
ensuite émerge la culture geek la
science-fiction les jeux vidéos et ça
masculinise très vite toute la filière
donc assez naturellement les femmes
elles se désintéressent de
l'informatique
alors dans les en 2014 j'avais
l'impression d'être dans les années 60 à
peu près et les gens autour de moi ils
reproduisaient sans s'en rendre compte
le comportement de leurs parents et
leurs grands-parents
et en réalisant pas les biais en
conscient auquel ils étaient soumis et
reproduisait l'histoire
mais en fait des biens en conscients on
a la touche tous les jours
et c'est pas vraiment une autre faute en
fait c'est notre cerveau qui pense avoir
mieux que nous
et on a aussi tous le sentiment que
l'histoire nous a emmené ici que c'est
notre destin
mais c'est faux
on peut changer le cours des choses il
est pas immuable
on a tous la capacité d'inverser la
tendance et de construire le futur
donc pour ça il faut raconter l'histoire
la vraie celle de la tech au féminin
et libérer nos biens conscients en
réalisant les comportements qu'on
maîtrise pas tout à fait parce que c'est
votre cerveau qui prend des questions à
notre place
et c'est comme ça qu'on va s'assurer
qu'on les reproduit plus
mais souvenez-vous dans les années 50
les scientifiques les ingénieurs c'était
des rois que ça
on les trouvait partout dans les films
dans les séries dans les journaux
c'était des figures populaires et
médiatiques
mais des rocksters aujourd'hui on a
plein encore
par exemple Cathie Bauman
elle a participé à photographier le
premier trou noir de l'histoire et ça
c'est très récent
assurons-nous de ne plus reproduire
l'histoire ou passer
soyons des rockstars les femmes comme
les hommes
merci
[Applaudissements]